welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and the batman returns say with some
amazing new images that tease out what
could be happening in the film
there's been a whole host of new pics
that showcase the set as well as some
ice looking sneak peeks for what we
could be getting in the movie
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking it all down but if you're new
to the channel
then i'd love it if you subscribed as
we're almost at the 400 000 mark
and it would mean the world to me to hit
that before the end of the year
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the marvel phase two box set
to people who are part of our community
but i'll talk more about how you can win
that towards the end of the video
anyway i don't want to end up a bruised
wayne
and even without a sidekick i'm not into
robin
so i'd be remiss if i didn't shout out
iso images
uav limited for getting these pics of
the set
full credit to them and there are some
absolutely amazing shots here
now the first one we need to talk about
is what appears to be the bat cave
when the trailer came out it did look
like batman was operating from a disused
train station
as we could notice tracks and staircases
that seem to be part of it
however from what we can see it does
look like bruce upgrades things at some
point
and actually moves into the cave which
is of course found on the grounds of
wayne manor
these images paint out the location to
be a sprawling network of cavernous
rocks
as well as some lush overgrown trees and
bushes that really bring it to life
now when i first saw this i did get a
lot of echoes of batman zero yeah
namely the graphic novel dark city
funnily enough
that's actually a story that takes place
in batman's early years
if we're going off the new 52 continuity
and it sees riddler taking over gotham
city
the place becomes an overgrown
wilderness full of trees and abandoned
buildings
and batman gets very steampunk on his
motorbike as he tries to take him down
i'm not sure whether they have enough
time to do that entire arc in one film
but at the very least we do know that
bruce will be slipping into something
a bit more appropriate for his lair if
you've been following our coverage on
the film so far then you'll know we've
discussed various leaks in report that
say batman will go through numerous
upgrades throughout the film
whilst i won't get into too much detail
here as i can't be bothered to edit in a
spoiler warning
i do suggest that your christian bail or
skip ahead 30 seconds
if you don't want anything potentially
ruined now if you've seen the images of
the character
that are out in public now then you'll
know that he goes from having a bike to
a car
and it's been rumored that throughout
the film he'll get numerous other things
as part of his tech
such as a new bat suit after the
explosion at the church causes issues
with the current one
matt reeves said that this batman was a
very diy one who was just starting out
so it does make a lot of sense for him
to go from a run down train station
to a rundown cave i'm just kidding it
looks
okay it reminds listen yet it reminds me
of two-face
because it's not half bad hey you having
that
subscribe button's right there now i
also love how there's what appears to be
god rails around the outskirts of
it and though i don't know whether these
will be removed for the film or not
it does remind me a lot of the ones that
were outside the bat cave in the 1966
adam west show
sorry i'm just remembering how bad that
joke was now on top of this
we've also got a sprawling city set that
looks absolutely incredible
it's safe to say that gotham is still a
complete dump
and this actually appears to be gotham
harbor which we know will likely be in
the film
due to its inclusion in the trailer in
the trailer we saw what looked to be the
penguin doing a deal down at the docks
with a mysterious figure
and though i can't quite make it out in
the photographs apparently the big steel
doors that we can see at the back
have the words gotham harbour iceberg
fishing co on them
now the penguin of course owns a club
called the iceberg lounge
and it seems that we may have also got a
look at that too though i can't be 100
sure
what i do know though is that a giant
ice rink was being built
and there were several cranes seen
placing statues and set dressing there
throughout the day
the snow could definitely just be the
weather at the time however
due to the connection of iceberg fishing
co and this set
i do think that it could indeed be the
infamous location
now if we pull out slightly there also
seems to be a checkered floor
and you might remember that a while back
we reported there would be a giant chess
board that was used in the film
i'm not sure whether this is it in all
honesty i know very little about set
design in general
so this could just be being used to mark
things out and make sure that the
measurements are right
the squares are absolutely massive
compared to the people
and i'd be a bit of an idiot saying that
it was confirmed because of this when
when really it isn't what i will do
though is ramble on about it
to bump up the run time of this video
now why i've said
i don't know if this is the iceberg
lounge or not or if it's just the time
period in gotham
is because we did see some of the
streets had a lot of snow lining them
from the trailers and first looks it was
clear that gotham wasn't in the midst of
its winter
but here it is so it's safe to assume
that the time period of the film
will take place over at least a couple
of seasons now why i'm bringing this up
is because the film is reportedly based
on the long halloween
if you read that then you'll know that
the storyline of the work spans
months and months and months throughout
batman's early years
and that could hint to how long of a
time frame that the film will take place
in
in the source material there's a killer
who murders mob figures in gotham on
every one of the holidays
and because of this they go by the
nickname holiday
great writing there now from the trailer
we know that the riddler
look i'm just kidding yeah long
halloween is one of the best batman
graphic novels ever so go
read it anyway from the trailer we know
that the riddler will be killing people
like the mayor
and also gotham's d.a so that does tie
in slightly with this aesthetic
batman is clearly gonna be in for a
tough time and this tough winter
makes me think we could get a movie that
spans up to and over a year
so we can see not only how the crimes
affect the city but a lot more
if the rumors about batman upgrading are
correct then he would need a lot of time
to do this and thus if things take place
over a long period of time
then it gives him the opportunity to
scout out the cave upgrade his tech
and also add things to the car that's
what makes the most sense to me at least
and whereas the ben affleck film was
rumored to be taking place in arkham
asylum over the space of one night
i think it's quite good that this one
may take place over a long period of
time
so we can see the rise and fall of
gotham now on top of this the drone
pilot also caught some images of some
american cars
and a skip that says gotham recycling on
it clearly they're trying to really
build up the authenticity of the movie
with these sets
and i i just can't believe how big it
all is there was also one that showed
gotham is still a complete mess
and we can spot a giant blue screen
behind it i'm guessing that this is to
fill in the skyline of the scene and
that they'll be getting more of the
stereotypical
towering skyscrapers that we're used to
seeing and just inserting them into
there
unless they make poor little jimmy have
to build all those skyscrapers from
scratch
get back to work you scumbag anyway
that's pretty much the majority of the
images that we have
and i think they all look great yeah
they look good don't they this has got
me really hyped up for the film
and even though it's two years away i
can wait
that's because i'm a silent guardian a
watchful protector
a spoiler man spoiler man do whatever a
spoiler can
what's that is that everything yeah i
think it is i think we're good here now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the updates
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our full
breakdown of all the scidaca updates
which will be linked at the end
as i mentioned earlier we're giving away
three copies of the marvel phase two box
set and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the one is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of november so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat is on the discord
server linked in the description
or heavy swellers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care
peace
you